va falloir tout nous raconter
je vous dirais que dalle allez vous
faire
profiter toute la journée ça ne fera car
perso moi de mon côté je vous dirai tout
ce que tu t'es comme
michael bryce voulait oublier son passé
songez à une reconversion
professionnelle
répétez après moi je ne suis plus gardes
du corps je ne suis
plus
les gardes du corps mais le passé sur
j'ai à nouveau
patricia ce qu'il doit protéger la femme
du plus cinglés d'être heures qu'est ce
qui faut aussi lui j'ai dit trouve qui
tu veux à part michael bright je pense
que tu voulais dire merci
dans quatre jours toute l'europe pour
l'heure il met sur pied une cyberattaque
géante attentions sont évitables merdé
ne vous inquiétez pas on va perdre et
j'ai promis à ma thérapeute je ne
protège plus personne noire était il
faut qu'ils restent concentrés léger
jérémie vous inquiétez pas je conduis
faites ce que vous avez à faire faut que
tu appuyer un peu sur le frein il faut
que tu nous protège on essaie d'avoir un
bébé
puisse dieu avoir pitié de nos seins
répète après moi j'ai pas de licence
j'ai pas de licence c'était
plus fort c'est pas de licence et j'en
ai rien à [__] il nous faut des armes
il faut débattre il nous faut c'est ça
vous êtes prêt à vous défoncer quoi ça
peut prêter à confusion pas vous
défoncer l'un l'autre mais avec nous ça
peut aussi prêter à confusion
alors faisons ce qu'on sait faire le
mieux allons tous faire exploiter
[Musique]
oui mais je ne serai pas une super maman
et d'un changement merci c'est sur
menthon désintérêt total pour le sec ce
qui fait de toi un homme de grande
écoute
[Musique]
je voudrais vous faire remarquer que
nous sommes sont sécurité c'est vraiment
comme un nouveau déclin